Yeah,
Dude.
Who won?
2018 Olympia.
This guy,
dude.
His abs are Blatt.
It's weird.
How come?
That's okay with black faces,
they are allowed to wear that stuff that makes your skin look dark so that you
can see the muscles better,
but they get to a point where it's literally,
it's blackface,
it's black body,
and we just accept it.
Well,
not only that,
you have to pretend you're one car.
Yeah.
You do either accept the fact that you're in chocolate body and chocolate face.
What is that?
That's not real.
I think that might be real.
He totally didn't go chocolate face,
chocolate body like this.
They're deer.
Literally spray tanning is people.
Exactly what?
They're deer and turning that guy black.
If they listen,
man,
I get it.
Black guys look better.
You're just going to have to deal with see the muscle fiber.
I agreed to just be white body.
I'll read the first one is that for say this lady total chocolate face.
How dare you do that?
The most chocolate face.
She's dark chocolate face.
Damn Dude.
That's okay.
It's okay bro.
It's a fitness Olympia.
I'm just showing you how rip my face,
my face is shredded as fuck.
I chew gum all day,
Bro.
When I want to stop,
I don't show my fucking cheeks or has wrapped faces ripped bro.
Look Bro,
how many people just want to wear black face cause they're super racist and they
can't so they become bodybuilders.
Does that happen dude?
I'm not saying it happens a lot,
but has it happened once as just a fucking bodybuilder,
bro?
Get over it,
ma'am,
ma'am.
Yeah,
get over it and he starts like rapping and shit
for all you bodybuilders out there.
We don't really care.
No,
keep doing it.
A chocolate bar it.
Yeah,
we really don't encourage it because it's hilarious and it makes you look
better.
You're right.
It's an advantage.
Chalking it up,
bro.
Yeah,
you're right.
Who wants to be more chocolate?
And the only reason why you should go chocolate face is because otherwise it's
super distracting.
Cause now you gotta go all now.
I don't think you're Tan.
I think you're crazy.
You're crazy.
What's going on?
Do you have like a suit on?